all right and we are live the last word
the campfire returns Lord Cognito and
ebon TISS back in the building man it
feels good to be back but I actually got
some fun last week it was good actually
seen you again but we got to hang out
that was cool yes yes shoutouts you got
to go to a really cool wedding it
sounded like so that was our two lady
SWAT lady panda the royal ceremony was
fantastic
complete gamer wedding so that was
awesome like if your your a game with
like the little nuances they had at
their wedding was so everything was so
geeked out it just left a good place in
my heart I was like yes this is my boy
right here they buried it was great man
so that was cool and then obviously you
don't see and I was in the area so you
know I had to see if the cheetah was
roaming if he was available approved
super propose is tasty stuff so know
what she's talking like sponsoring I
like tacos so send them on over it would
AFI approves it a twin dad that would be
a little too chichi like Taco J good
little spots and they are for sure
absolutely Vettel back in a breather
since you've been enjoying a little
festivities so shout out to the ninja by
the way everybody in the podcast get a
little love out there hit him up on
Twitter at Lord Cognito blow up the
Twitter for his birthday festivities we
are recording today he's gonna go get
drunk tonight who knows what he's gonna
do he might not know what tomorrow is
but for now send him a little love out
there on the Twitter's guys blow up
history show him a good time not too
much of a good to keep it clean much
appreciated
it's gonna be a while but most likely
but uh so this probably most sober you
will see me that's why we do it I stress
that is true that is true but oh you
guys I'm gonna creaky
you're saluting the chest lift everybody
for the birthday wishes man yeah
definitely another one but oh yeah we
got some fun we could talk a little
destiny before those festivities but I'm
excited man I got my pre cake so I'm
good I was working on something over
there so if you're watching if you're
listen to this on audio you don't get to
see what he's eating
I think it's ice cream I can't tell but
if you guys are catching this on video
you guys know we do listen to this on
audio we are on your podcast platform of
choice just about all of them so Spotify
iTunes Google Play you guys can find us
there
I do upload those shortly after this
thing is done so if you guys find us
there you can also find us in the video
forum if you want to see what our mugs
look like over here while we eat ice
cream at least one of us you can come
check us out on our YouTube channels
both on ebon to see YouTube channel in
the iron Lords podcast we're all over
the place so if you guys listen on audio
final some video if you like the video
but you want to take us on the go you
got audio as well and I just wanted to
shout out for you guys just to sponsor
the podcast we got anchor they have been
a great source to host the podcast for
us they have been really easy to work
with so quick little sponsor break for
them and then we will be right back
alright so I just want to thank you guys
for tuning out today I know we got a
different time for the podcast just work
schedules and birthday festivities so an
afternoon Friday one for you guys but
for the birthday man you get the honors
what have you been up to this week sir
playing anything gaming sleeping a lot
who knows what even up to yeah this is
kind of vacation for me obviously I kind
of pre-planned it but um yeah I've been
doing a little destiny I got a little
desk actually go I'm you're gonna laugh
at a fun little story I did like doing
like old raids so I actually saw I'm
doing that because my brother I was
playing with him and yes I looked and I
was like what are you doing and then I
was like you do like PC sleeper catalyst
or something is that oh you don't know
me Dobby called a joke called it bro you
call that I basically I need I had to
convince and it took all type of
convincing for them to even attempt
spire of stars would be so how I tricked
them and I say look I know
like podcast yes or something like that
go go go look it's only listen I said
the catalyst drops at any chest and the
Econo said we don't even got to do the
rain telling just got to do the first
part maybe the jump and puzzle we got to
opportunites for chair we'll stop so I
get up round up people shout to addicts
at the center snake liar he's a complete
lie I was like trying to get this thing
done oh really I really want this
catalyst because you know I'm a sleeper
fan something like alright so I get them
to do it we get through the first run
and it went well nobody got a drop which
was weird I thought it was maybe
guaranteed
you know maybe each part but ok nobody
really got just anything the catalyst
catalyst so I'm like alright so then we
get to the jumping puzzle which is
hilarious with tossing the football
around doing that whole thing so we get
it and then it's now it's time to get
the chance all right
touch it now should I wait for other
guys so like two other guys touching I'm
gonna jump in now didn't get it so I'm
like alright cool so then I'm waiting
and we like you know let's go we gotta
go to the next section so addicts like
you I haven't got there yet just wait by
the chest I'm alright cool this I was so
angry it dropped for him and he didn't
even care he didn't even want this he
was the person that really didn't want
to do it and I'm sitting out he's like
so that he's doing like emojis but his
character we do a heroic and the loadout
was awful for all we had hand cannon
primary I believe sniper
I just got terrible snipers in my energy
I don't have good energy snipers and I
think any anything for arm the new
prostates pretty good yeah which I which
I don't have
and so basically I was running I think I
won the ace of spades
some weird energy shoddy I mean I'm
sniper and I think I'm gonna say
delirium that was what I was running
with but I was just it it's not bad but
again with the ads and and everything
that was coming up it's just again I
guess they've scale your light level
down a little bit yeah so you know
you're not really feeling like you're
1920 above and that's about it you're
not like - yeah
you'll never truly opie and destiny that
is one thing about this game you never
truly get to be like a god yes
yet we have yes gods but we don't ever
get to feel like one we'll get the feel
like that so yeah shutting shut up the
Attic so his punishment now is he must
every reset he must him and sinister
much run spire stars with me because
that eliminates those two from getting
the catalyst since they already have it
so that's his punishment well he was
showcasing and getting on my nerves in
my face he's doing little emotes like oh
you mean this this is what you want this
guy oh boy salud addict man I'll get
that thing eventually nice what about
you man what you been black destiny
mm-hmm and then that may switch as soon
as we get done with this well we'll get
to that later but for now my brother and
I finished the dungeon so we went full
through nice so stone wolf and I made it
through dungeons start to finish
oh nice so I kind of was I'd gone
through the first couple encounters like
mainly up to the totem and I knew what
to do it looked at a video or two he
didn't really know what's going on so
basically I just kind of let him lead
the way on a couple sections the best
one was the ogres I was like yeah all
right
we literally like you drop down and you
have like before you tunnels to go
explore I was like all right don't mourn
and somebody in chat was like explore
he's like I know girls like all right I
need to trust the peek and maybe finds
the enemies let me start roaming around
and kind of steer him into it got xeno
fades while we were in there so finished
that one literally at the same time got
a funny story to tell you about that
shelter will hope Wilhelm scream I'll
tell you my story afterwards oh yeah we
got it oh yeah you show you what the
story though yeah always might be more
entertaining than mine because mine
seems a very tame versus your quote sure
sorry
shout out the scream that principal if
you're not subscribed to Wilhelm scream
like please subscribe to this man so
coool one of the coolest in the
investment community he met him through
he bounces and um we just chill in one
day and i forgot he jumped in my discord
it's like hey what are you guys doing
and I told him the whole stuff I was
working on did you get xenophanes yet
and I'm like
oh say he's like oh yeah I get it -
we're getting for you down by like 15-20
minutes hmm
I was like well I haven't unlocked the
dungeon I still really haven't attempted
all that stuff I'm saving it so he's I
don't know we're about it
sure enough the little screen finds away
there's apparently a way to glitch in I
just watch speedruns where people will
like dude loading zone or something
because I watch the speedrun there's a
world record speed run out there of like
five minutes
Wow of the whole damn dungeon which is
Wow but they use some like loading skip
is that what you ended up you know dis
this was just it was almost legitimately
starting it you look Jim Lee started cuz
you know how you get in there and then
you kind of got to descend down right so
you're in the necropolis and you're
starting to sit there and then he knows
a spot where it's a specific tower where
you stand on and then you kind of jump
between the the tower and the mountain
he's like literally fall through the
geometry and with this joy he got little
and then what's crazy is you get I think
the older part that you're talking about
is that what is that the next sequence
do you have to fight some witch at the
bottom and you have to kind of use the
correct thing you're supposed to because
you it's in the ogre room you have to
find the right door you have to clear my
ogres out first then you run this thing
around hit all these little torch plates
then the door opens go into the doors
right yep okay so when we go down it is
nobody's no ogres there's no nothing in
the witch is there but we get into that
rule with the witch she's dead you got
to fight yeah but you can't really fail
the encounter so to speak even if all of
us die kind of thing so yeah we're just
doing the thing everybody's getting the
correct
essence of whatever it is so that you
can do DPS and then once we got that
part I guess the final step for
xenophanes was like okay we got it
and then you can pack the air there's
like there you go it was funny so I was
like I don't even want the gun cuz I was
like the guns not no good but he's like
yo they're gonna buff it we talked about
and I was like alright you know what
navigating so shout-out to one screen
for my unofficial
haven't even unlocked the dungeon and
you have xeno phage impressive by the
way
far better than I did I'm a schmuck and
did in the normal way geez cheese
forevers YouTube channel I have no
intention I blame scream you would just
like look bit I can make your life easy
right now but you definitely broke me
was supposed to see it normal I'm gonna
do it no no I am gonna do it though
salute to him well I'm a schmuck and I
did it the normal way so there's that
yeah
but yeah so the quest you kind of go
through you start a couple pieces
outside the dungeon you go in and you're
just kind of running around and trying
to figure out where to go and I had
looked up a little bit but I was just
kind of mostly going by like where to go
and then I was kind of like you got to
the door section I was like all right
which door and then I kind of peeked
what door and I was like alright so I
was just trying to have my brother this
is where I was like letting my brother
go first
so propolis you kind of go down you keep
falling and then you get to all the
doors before you get into kind of the
next section with the totems and stuff
like that and when you're doing the door
section there's the like the-- oryx you
know felt like projectiles that will
kick you out of there so I told him to
go explore is like hate go right now
that door he's like I'm not gonna do
that
he's like I was like just like no
something's gonna hit me I was like
you're right so I showed him what it
looked like from his perspective and
then I was like okay you have like 15
doors figure out where to go he was like
thrown around not a big fan of jump in
finally figured out where we've like
proceeded forward and I was like all
right there's a quest thing and then
he's like take him up to that spot then
we go through the over oh I hate that
spot I know what you - we had to do that
and you they will get annoyed when we
that jump you talk about all those doors
and they're saying and you gotta tell
doors you gotta get up - yes yes yeah
the Maurya call I Section to marry oh
yeah and the Warlocks the best one to do
it on you guys awful it's awful I was
struggling bro it's like literally Zia
shout to screen he's I bro
turn your brightness all the way up cuz
I couldn't see
did he was literally having to shoot and
throw grenades and where I need to go
but if it wasn't for scream I was not
doing that by my jumping was awful the
flu if I was falling up and it was
drinking too much so you're gonna stop
that day but yeah so just it's a cool
place it's a cool encounter finish the
whole thing when we got to the final
boss I think it was just he and I the
whole time so to man the whole thing we
did - man the Vezina phage boss so the
wizard so you're like trying to figure
out like I hadn't actually looked up the
mechanics and we're like okay so we got
the four and then we figure out the buff
you got to pick up the red buff to do
damage to her and then it was on the
rotation was like give me my machine gun
am i super or something because I wasn't
set up with the right loadout so we were
working on her down then after that I
was like okay now we got to go do the
totem we did the totem on the first try
Wow yeah my brother never just like cuz
I've worked on the solo test so I can do
like dunking cycles by myself I just
haven't done all six because that's just
that's a whole lot then a lot of things
can go wrong
beau and him I was just like alright so
what we're gonna do and it's honestly if
you're running with two or three people
this is the way you want to kind of do
it two's not bad actually cuz every
night you killed drops an orb and like
every shadow orb in any strike it has
like an internal timer but if you pick
it up and set it down it resets we said
all you got to do is just kind of like
walk it back and forth across the
totally pick it up set it down pick it
up walk it across so like we would kill
the first night I'd go I'm like okay
I'll go get the first one okay come back
and just taking it back and forth I'm
like okay I'll hold down the ads find
your knight that you want to go kill
okay we've dropped him together you ran
out pick it up dunk dunk if you dunk
like within about a second basically as
soon as you can like dunk and then do it
again if you do them both together you
only get one phase of ads now shout out
to either Daddo or glad or some random
video I watched if you do them close
enough together you have only one phase
of ads which is nice because it's only
one set of boomers it's only one set of
thrall and it's a lot more manageable so
with the two of us after I'd worked on
most it up by myself I brought in a bow
which still works machine gun and then
good old izanagi I really actually know
I would use
jeezum thinking is my old dread
adventure I got it's just another day to
sniper
it's got like wrapping hit and rampage
so it just gets like a truck so yeah
between he and I man just at first try
and then the boss fight we talked about
that boss fight boss fights cool boss
fight is cool
so big boy the encounters you learn in
the Necropolis
are what you use the mechanics of for
the boss itself because you got to get
three orbs to basically kick off the
boss damage phase once the shrinker once
the knight ones the wizard so you got a
block melee and range kill all those
Duncan dunk those and then stand in the
green section to kill the big boy mm-hmm
well when Big Boy's going on he's thrown
a couple like pools of fire on the
ground and it's always the crappy car
stalls that ruin your day yeah Kurt's
they're all man they're just like and I
feel like that place cuz it's
recommended 9:40 I'm pretty sure that
place is like the end of its probably
like nine eighty because that place
hurts yes like that final fight hurts a
lot but no fight I definitely know
depending on your damage setup I know I
saw esoteric kill them in like two
minutes or like one phase them in
insanity man's a beast shout out this
kind of shut up disguise but yeah that
like the fight itself is a patience game
more than anything else is just now
rushing it cuz like okay so you got a
kill a sword guy okay go run up and
smack the guys just don't get too
over-the-top like if I can if I ever do
like a solo flawless run it's gonna be
the totem part that kills me it's not
gonna be the final boss fight I'll screw
up the final boss fight by something
dumb getting greedy like staying in the
right stupid place the totems just like
pure chaos for like six ducks like
that's the hard part but him you're
you're gonna be killing enough ads
you're bound to get enough ammo sniper
or something so always be able to get
some damage into the boss I just use
something like oppressive darkness knife
snipe snipe
reload well of radiance or bubble ward
of dawn either one of those grenade him
throw that shoot him go out and do the
cycle again like there's
timer enraged so you can just write as
much time as you need you tell time you
need got you like the solo flawless I
can see many people have done an already
I'm behind but in can be done so it was
really cool I was like I still haven't
quite decided where it rates against
shattered throne but I think most
awesome dungeons in their own right like
okay like I don't know if I was going to
go me I don't know if ones overall
better than the other they both have
cool encounters and experiences and
feels to them I enjoy both a lot like
dungeons for me low-key or probably like
so far still both of them now my
favorite thing in destiny let me ask you
a reverse like all kind of heresy for
yeah every guy should a reverse question
so what do you think that what aspect of
shattered throne do you like better than
pit of heresy is there any aspects of
shadow tone that you like okay I like
the way this was done a little better or
just maybe maybe just you know certain
parts are more fun then maybe not that
I'm trying to steer you that way I just
want to know if there because I see you
still hold a daughter sherry you ain't
necessarily put pit here you still kind
of here in here with it which is fine
it's like pit of heresy I really like
the ogre section versus like the shadow
the shadow thrall section because you
have sections where you're like limit
down and movement you got to kind of
spice the like spots to hide but the
shadow they're all just like kind of
baby they'll smack you around a little
bit but you just slowed so it's just
like okay just kind of got a hope hop
over them and kind of take my little
Moses the ogres is more of like
intensely like oh here it comes slide
back in the door and it's like it's a
little more hectic like heart racing
moments so that one's actually kind of
cool as for the best way I can compare
like if you go fights like Dolan carros
versus Olmec or whatever his name is I
think you've got four gets the ogre
versus the totem is how I would compare
those and then kind of just the others
are somewhat matched together the
opening section like necropolis is a
copy of the oh of Erebus like the one I
did the math Micropolis is right very
similar it's like figure out which ones
you got to go to which runes do I need
to unlock take these here new mechanics
so there's a little more mechanics like
with the sword which I do like yes yes
yeah the verticality of Necropolis looks
cool when you're trying to go up to the
top you gotta get up there let me go
find a lift jump over here go past all
the guys I like the fact that shattered
throne is just you're gonna clear them
all at some point and you know you've
got to the other ones random and you're
like okay where do I go did I go to the
wrong one crap it's on the other side so
it's kind of an up-and-down thing there
I don't know I'll have to get back to
you on that one for official well made
that's all I enjoy sad dramatic he says
he loved the ascendant realm it's so
cool and creepy
Jarvis vinius sir welcome to it
Jarvis if you guys don't know his
YouTube channel I'm gonna look it up and
link it here in a second but definitely
find that man look him up mm-hmm well
anything else you've been doing lately
no I was doing I was doing a lot of
badass and festival I'm almost finished
with them with the the whole pretty tech
thing I finally started getting grinding
but I played it a torn of Iron Man
turner my mana but before it was up what
it was up and um again shout out to the
team shout to scream leave Kaiba to
sinister attic we would just here in the
record shop having a having a ball and
oh shout out to pinnacles +2 whoo we
haven't talked about that oh it's
fantastic man it is fantastic
but really enjoying it it felt good to
get beneficial drops I saw when I did my
banners you know had the four had the
pinnacles on deck that felt good um if
that was the other thing on crime so
troubling there - once you start
leveling up like 951 952 prime yeah okay
Prime's aren't totally useless thank you
good job yeah well I was worried that
everything was gonna be useless but the
primes gonna help fill holes which is
nice yeah it's been a nice slow grind
with it man so again really it's a
subtle change you know everyone's gonna
go crazy but for me I really really
liked it man but yeah that's pretty much
it you know slowly not getting back into
the swing you know I'm saying of playing
destiny regular and then again we got a
lot of stuff to talk about I can't wait
but uh yeah that's pretty much
yeah yes pretty much it for me yeah that
pretty much wraps up the past now I
don't think either of us have touched
this game of that came out last week the
divisive controversial package-delivery
balancing act yeah no lady yet I am very
intrigued by deaths training if you guys
don't know what I'm talking about
PlayStation game sample people may hate
it some people might love it you may
think it's for you you may not might be
vice versa right but all like I have
like a friend of mine play with him all
the time
yeah known him forever I never expected
him to enjoy it like he is probably 3/4
of the way through this game trying to
beat it before you start Star Wars which
we'll talk about later but like Ness
training is one of those like it's just
you hear all the pot I have never heard
more interesting discussion like isn't
is this for you is this a game is it art
it's like it's been interesting to have
something like that out in the wild to
be like it's not a game we just shoot
stuff in the face like so many games are
that and it just being so different is
still kind of cool so I'm intrigued
don't know if I'll play it if you are
there let me know somewhere in a tweet
or comment I'm curious yeah I will say
this this is probably for as long as
I've been gaming and I'm old um I would
say it's probably the most polarizing
triple-a game I've ever seen reviewed
and commenting on I've never seen such
stark disparity you know me it's either
like again oh it's it's art it's it's
unique like you said it's just it's not
just shooting things
you know do drawing or whatever whatever
and unless I give it credit to decimate
engine everything looks fantastic and
then I made the other side which is like
well the core mechanics this is a ups
simulator and Fenig you know you've
really jokes you know obviously so it's
it's a subjective thing and I'm saying I
think fun is subjective you know I don't
I know for me I don't think it's for me
you know based on what I've seen and
stuff like that but I know people like
you and like your friend us am yeah
that's I wouldn't even think would love
something and they're like yo I'm in
crow
I'm loving it you and I'm saying that
kind of Takata traumatic so Amazon the
jokes area to joke sorry this is like
but oh yeah you know what we'll see hey
I think it's I don't know if I'm I'm
very curious to see what your feel is
because whenever I get around to it
I am I'm really curious to because it
may be one like my friend may like a
aspect of about it and I may not as I
don't know it's one of those games I
don't know and even listen like podcast
beyond shadow taiji and it's like those
guys are always like kind of on the
poles they're even like it's not like I
can say it's not like God of War horizon
zero dawn right this is an amazing game
on all fronts cool gameplay story
narrative feel like set pieces it's it's
it's own thing and it's like it may or
may not be for everybody and I just
think that's what kind of as we I mean
Call of Duty came like Call of Duty this
is actually pretty good we don't have
battlefield we're missing like
Assassin's Creed we don't have our usual
like lineup some things but we have
these other games coming that I'm very
intrigued by which is nice so it's been
fun to kind of like want to actually be
want to be pulled away from destiny for
something it doesn't happen often and
there's a couple things right in this
past like week and a half when I'm like
mm-hmm
I need more time I don't know like I
want to play three games at the same
time and I don't same time it's like row
me you just seen and I'm sitting in I'm
looking at my outer world which that's
that's my additional oh my god I love it
it's just I'm like I don't have time for
all these things and did you know
destiny wants to do little things to get
you back it it's tough man it's tough I
will say this last one for mourn is that
with the new hard cap pinnacle grime I
feel this allows us a little more time
to at least attempt other things whereas
before I think the way the old chase was
set up we'd be so engrossed now we know
okay it's just these pinnacles it's just
this activities kind of thing you know
I'm saying where's before I felt we were
like a little bit more invested with the
the hardcore you know endgame grind so
that's just me I don't know what how you
felt about that you
yeah I mean I am curious cuz there's
like the floating theory out there of
mmm how what's gonna happen next season
yeah
are we gonna go through the powerful Xan
level up is the pinnacle grind gonna get
bumped is everything just going back
down to like whatever your gear score is
and you just start off with the artifact
only late mm-hmm
I mean then what a flake so it's
artifact only but then your pinnacle can
go up to like 974 gear score over the
season and the artifact can go even
higher so it's like I'm wondering and
they have not clarified that and I think
that's because I'm not entirely sure if
they knew what they wanted is when they
started like is next season gonna be 50
level power cap and then it's the
pinnacles ten thousand ten seems like I
don't know if they're gonna make that
leap yet so I'm we're not that far away
from the next season and I honestly
don't know how that pinnacle grind is
gonna continue because they have not
once ever confirmed because that's the
bit like listening to a Rachel surround
table it's like Paul Tassie
is like how do you not have powerful
gear all these different activities
level you up for another 50 levels right
and this is the whole like grassy knoll
thing that's like day one and then the
other because but on the other side of
the low note was sitting there saying
it's like okay so how do they want to
make these ala cart seasons not feel
people are like a hundred power levels
behind if they season like 10 skip
season of dawn come in and they still
feel like they can jump into it and I'm
like I don't know how to answer both of
those questions with you that with the
same answer it's like I don't it's tough
it's tough the only thing I can think if
you kind of meet in the middle is um
they do what Tassie said which is just
kind of the traditional way that we're
used to playing destiny right that's the
only thing I was thinking I was thinking
I did have to do what they do like how
when I started drifter they started
menagerie there's some you go to the NPC
there's some mini quest and gives you
the Blues that get you to the light
where you need I don't see them
abandoning that I think that kind of um
that is my favorite I think they've
Connors established that that's a
problem when a new a new expansion comes
out you're always gonna have people who
either skipped or missed so here's a way
Paul
FastTrack them you know get them up to
whatever it is 9 59 60 whatever it is
and then maybe they do it that way it is
interesting yeah and that's kind of
where it's like the debate of okay well
how worth it is that the pinnacles
because in three weeks then I'm just
gonna pass it up in my first three blues
like that's where the debate of the
pinnacle grind if these things I think
they have the math wrong the plus two
feels a little better it makes it a
little more table some people got there
really fast yes you do three raids get
some good drops get a decent night heavy
drop and you move pretty fast so it's
like is that what it was supposed to be
and then it's like okay here's a little
boost for the pinnacles and then more
mm-hmm
or was it supposed to be ultra slow so
it's just like I'm very curious to see
when words old yeah that will be because
I'd like to you know officially like
how's this gonna work in the future so
then you can actually plan around like
do I care about the pinnacle do I not is
it worth the righthand for a little
bonus or do I take little breaks like
until now I don't know so that's I think
I think they read I think they're
redefining it bro yeah I got this gut
but I think I've kind of alluded to it
the last couple of last words I think
they're redefining the pinnacle grind is
more I don't wanna say just bragging
rights but I almost feels like you know
if you want to do it you know for a
little slight bump that's your hardcore
endgame and you keep playing you chase
you do that but I think they're cool
with like cuz the fact that this is not
a minor pinnacle sources leads me to
believe that this is the new philosophy
change again I could be reaching but it
just it just feels that way it feels
it's like you know you had not fit to
you good but if you want this extra
stuff you want to still keep going you
got something to brag about because you
did XY and Z and the only thing I'm
hoping is that it's it's sufficient
enough for the hardcore to say hey I'm
cool with this or let you know let's see
how it goes on we got to see how it
plays on from the season a dawn is gonna
ask us so many questions so many
questions and speaking of that we know
nothing about it I don't know a damn bit
of anything with related that we can
speculate we can hope mineral in to your
mercury favorite man of all time know
whatever it is we don't know anything it
is not that far away I know how how far
where's that calendar we gotta pull that
up we are
three weeks left in the season as of
Tuesday mmm so this Tuesday so four days
from now the season has three weeks left
another thing we don't know anything
about that starts on Tuesday is are we
going to have a tower there they're
going to be goblins roaming the tower
how are we going to kill them an undying
mind and a lot of times is it us the
mechs final assault starts on Tuesday
and we got nothing not an iota of
information in the table about the final
events which go ahead uh can I see I'm a
little disappointed that vex offensive
is not a pinnacle activity how would you
make it monocle Eva Soler uh trade you
got the dungeon right you've got master
nightmares master nightfalls how do you
make vector do what you want another
difficulty it's just I don't know he
could they could do this like the normal
one to me doesn't justify pinnacle
because like you can dry right through
that thing yeah absolutely I'm not
saying that the way it's currently
constructed at its difficulty but yeah
just like I guess what bothers me about
it is that I feel like every other
season prior when that new activity was
introduced like a menagerie and you know
um you know drift her head you know
right let's go reckoning in all our
minds I felt that that was lowkey in him
and I like I find myself not even caring
about vex offensive and not that I hate
being the activity but it's like why am
I going to go in there what is the
benefit like I literally don't do it
anymore I was gonna ask you this
question are you doing vex offensive
these days no right so it's like I'm
animals that's a legitimate question is
like how do you get engaged especially
with the power Kappa set out again
you get to 950 it works as a decent tier
2 you're working with that core for the
tier 3 drop you get both of those police
coming through yeah that's fine so you
get those but then when you get to 950
you know it's not pinnacle and what are
you working on then you're working on
ritual weapons you're working on
pinnacle drops you're doing raids you're
doing dungeons you're doing other stuff
but you're not going to vex offensive
unless you
want a roll on a weapon and after sight
you're probably like I may have had what
I want or I don't but that's really your
only reason in there and it's like that
just begs the question of what is their
philosophy on the seasonal activity how
big is it gonna be is it meant to me
just like hey here's this thing that
moves the story forward
or is it me something that keeps you
engaged I honestly like I like you I'm
with you like give me another difficulty
give us a pinnacle version mm-hmm maybe
the VEX have felt maybe the final
assault is maybe yeah because you got to
kill the undying mind three times for
one of the triumphs right so if three
times is hard to do mm-hmm then maybe
it's like a pinnacle thing towards the
end of the season I hope so man because
I really think the way it was handled
was a misstep and there should be no
reason why we get this cool new I mean
I'm not saying it's the greatest we we
we've kind of write it in between
menagerie and what it's it's in the
middle right so it's just like damn I
could not even be it from me that's even
going next I said I'm like weightless
now look there's no pinnacle I tell me
if I'm wrong - there's not even a
powerful drop it looks like from it
anymore that was a thing like that did
that change dungeon launch week maybe
possibly because it's like because it
was at a point it was a powerful drop
now powerful girl helping me anymore per
se right but it was still a powerful up
until fourth week yeah
Italy so I don't know why for one that
shifted maybe it's getting ready for the
next fight like again this is the
question mark in the background that we
don't have answers to right and I just
honestly don't know
so yeah I am - shame so I'm curious well
how do you think because they've said
nothing about Mex final assault how do
you think is it just gonna be log in log
into chaos in the tower or just start
with a quest like they're not gonna tell
us figure it out is it truly just hey
everybody let's see what this thing's
all about do you think that's how it's
gonna go it feels like the narrative
build-up obviously we see a core a
building that thing and I love that
aspect of what they don't
I'd love every time you log in on you
know on reset and you're like wow like
this things happening something's
happening so it would be cool I don't
want to get too ahead of myself but so
far they've been cool with the when the
dungeon was lunch she got think we got
our Aris little cinematic you it would
be cool if we got just a brief cinematic
maybe vex in the towel whatever it's
gonna happen happen and yeah we just go
at it the key is you know fighting the
undying mind right you know in the
triumphs three times what have you you
know again is it going to be pinnacle
drop worthy is it where's the activity
gonna take place you know I do have some
questions to see how that's handled its
this is probably pretty much like the
last event vent right this is the end of
the season there's nothing else there's
nothing else after so Dave they've gotta
end this right they gotta end this right
because I think I'm me you but the jury
let's say the jury's still out on shadow
keep as a whole until we get past this
point yeah and then we can really we lo
I think I think it's fake stay safe to
say we love shadow key we don't hate it
but I think the way it ends is gonna
really also play how we rate this thing
when not in the grand scheme of
expansion so write a book until you read
all the chapters until you read the
chapter a quarter of the right so far so
right but we've all said we love garden
ourselves we don't think honors up
salvation strong we all love paid of
heresy you know I'm saying arm we did
this table viously there was a couple of
missteps is still no vendor refresh
still crucible these to be where it
needs to be and stuff like that as a
whole and um that's a whole level debate
you know will will last word that
forever but um you know it did jury I
think they need to end strong I think
they need to internally if they they end
strong put the cherry on the sundae
then it's our okay boom shadow keeps up
there with a lot of the grapes right a
lot of the ones that we those expansions
we Revere so um yeah I'm very curious
man a very crew see what what happens
there it's gonna be it's gonna be
interested in this uh this a little
final vex offensive so to speak to see
what they do
yep so Tuesday's gonna be big
portal open new quest and then do you
think it's gonna be back in the same
place we did the VEX offensive
do you think it's gonna be like all
different vex area think they're gonna
bring us back into the undying mind
strike like do you think it's actually
gonna be a different are they're gonna
reuse the same like assets they built or
do you think we're actually gonna see
new things I'm curious like I think they
have to do something something new in
the sense that again he Shrestha shadow
boy Luke but Luke said you know it's the
way these seasons are gonna play out is
you should have been there when this is
supposed to be either you should have
been there when moment right whereas you
know this she's building this thing
they're supposed to have a story
conclusion and like we're posted shout
out to the cars that keep coming back
this was that happy it's crazy traffic's
crazy today but up yeah it's supposed to
be you know a nice conclusion so I'm put
a little pressure on them they they got
it they got to do this thing right man I
don't I mean if they use I'll be a
little disappointed if it's a typical
you know what we've already been doing
kind of effects with you on that one
it's kind of the way black arm we're the
first was like hey this is a cool Forge
but there was not a lot of variation to
the forges besides it was a different
shaped room I mean that's the I mean
black armory I enjoy they're fun they're
cool mechanics you're fighting the
enemies with rubber balls to kill the
boss in the end but it's not like any of
them had anything different even if like
I honestly just wish when you got some
burgers easier there was like two new
you kind of had to hit him both or there
was some rye rye right tweaked to even
the final one for black memory was like
a big business for me because it's like
you go through all the big like crazy
dor puzzle situation you open it is the
same thing and I'm like I want something
else in there besides just a spider tank
like give you more so same thing here
it's like if it's a vex final assault
and then the only thing different at the
top is the undying mind we got to see
that we got to see all right if they do
that I better get some cool cinematics I
better get some something I'm gonna get
some you fight cuz up at the top there's
like that little portal in Meg's
offensive yeah everything
I know you come out yeah so like when
you fight the boss like on the upper
deck there's like a portal where you
finish it kind of the chest is maybe you
go through the VEX assault and you go
through that so gonna face something and
it's like a longer version of X final of
X offensive is the final assault where
you have to push farther maybe that's a
thing I don't know but that portal seems
in a weird spot otherwise maybe that's
it I don't know yeah I gotta do
something man
we won't know till Tuesday so state
takes out all the streams and stuff
we'll be doing that mm-hmm yes sir
uh so yeah Tuesday is a big giant
question mark the next season is still a
big giant question mark most aspects but
we do have a little tease about the
sandbox changes that are coming
Oh would you like to talk about some
changes that people expected but may not
be the happiest about depending on how
you play this game so I start with
seeking balance is that our paragraph
yes so from the development team man
over the last year made some changes to
the sandbox of destiny - so weapons have
been brought down some all have been
brought up and the meta has shifted from
class to class coming next season the
sandbox will evolve once more this week
we'll be looking at - note our pious
items I like notorious I like that then
you may have heard about Oh
Exhibit A there recluse changed what is
what could possibly change the effects
of master of arms remove the precision
damage modifier recruits will continue
to receive a damage bonus for massive
arms but damage will not default to
precision values when the perk activated
and then they get went to it as the
thought process many doubted the recluse
when it was first announced that is true
but it has since proved to be resilient
to being squashed
although the precision damage modifier
did not actually improve the Efes
efficacy always put your network
efficacy of the weapon at its best it
did allow for fair fairly mindless
spraying to be just as good as
concentrated aiming
after considering various options on
what to do with it the decision was made
to remove the part of the functionality
and preserve the activation methods the
alternative was leaving in an effect we
believe was too strong for a legendary
weapon let's go eat all over get it okay
yeah listen man I'm not excited about
our nerve so to speak so shots of my
recluse lovers I mean we knew this day
was coming like I mean it's to the point
and this yeah this this one you know
like I've always felt whenever you play
destiny and you're stuck in one load out
because it is by far the most efficient
loadout and God know what it is yes it
is most likely Izanagi and kinetic
reclusive energy and most likely a swarm
on the river which oh by the way I got
my first one with my grenades got to
tell you that yeah I about that teyla
I've joined the club Thank You Saladin
salute salute oh yes
so she's finally blessed me after like
five iron banners but enough of that
but yeah you got your swarm some form of
a grenade launcher you know in that spot
holding you down and don't get me wrong
from efficiency standpoint it makes
sense you're silly not to do any
pinnacle activities with that kind of
loadout but again I always feel destiny
is always more fun when you have that
variety and we're coming back to recluse
recluse is super strong anything Crocs
the master of arms and the precision
damage modifier I mean it's gonna it's
gonna play different you know I'm saying
I didn't think they would actually I
thought they was gonna do the opposite
to be on see I thought they would like
eliminate master of arms practing off of
any type of Carol know and then do leave
the damage modifier alone so it is
interesting the way they handle it and
I'm curious do you think in reference to
the way that has been nerfed is that the
correct core because one of my other
theories was maybe the
make it exotic but they never seemed to
do that strictly to a Hopi legendary so
I'm actually very curious about what you
think about this I mean they seem to
clarify a little bit so it says the
precision damage modifier basically just
seemed like whether you hit the body or
the head it would be precision damage
once you crap cracked Mastiff arms and
that's something I really can't say I
knew if that was anyway how that works
that's how that's go that goes that was
actually clarifying for me but then also
it's like so if you go for precision
shots you still get precision damage na
but you actually do have to aim you just
can't spray and hit him in the toe the
kneecap and the thigh and still do the
same amount of damage you actually have
to aim for they had to kill them quicker
so the time to kill is still probably
gonna be quick cuz it's fused but still
really fast I'm honestly gonna be
curious cuz range doesn't seem to be
touched the praça still is gonna be
there
and the damage if you're accurate
potentially could be the same kill time
if not like next to a bullet close so
I'm really not sure it's gonna change a
ton mm-hmm you just can't spew all over
a body and kill it in the same speed you
got it right of the part that matters
that matters right which it's
interesting it's gonna be interesting it
almost feels that they kind of went
delicate with it in the beginning and
like this seems to be the new mentality
right like do a little delicate nerve
first see how it's received for the most
part and then if it's still acting up
but which we'll talk about what our next
culprit then they go in extra hard after
the second or third one so um yeah I
don't know man I mean we I think it's
still gonna be pretty powerful I agree
you know law they basically just want
aim for the head the infrared just don't
mind let's pray you're still gonna get a
lot of you know efficient kills with it
and it like I say like II say he's still
gonna proc you're still gonna have that
range you
we will see how much this truly but I
put it this way I don't know if this
gonna truly deter people from not using
it yeah it seems like a small wing clip
as opposed to like taking the wings off
like yes it's a very minor tweak and I
think this comes from nerfing stuff into
the ground and having to bring it back
there trying not to completely gut
something they're trying to slowly edge
it in place now the fact that takes a
season to slowly edge something in place
since it's been around for a year is
weird some way they'd figure this out so
that's the balance it's like if you're
gonna go baby steps do them faster like
that just kinda seems things so I don't
know to be honest like if this thing
gets taken down a little bit I'd like to
see rhetorics and breakneck brat back up
a little too too hard
on the other side so if you feel like
you overdid it hey we're gonna buff
these two back up a little bit see if
they can get back into a place they
should be it's like they focus so much
on some I feel like others like I feel
like breakneck and rhetorics
I'm not really gonna be doing much for a
while cuz they're just like hey they're
pinnacles we don't wanna make them too
good again they're now they're out of
the meta they were never really too
strong we're not gonna touch them and
then unfortunately that means you're not
gonna get too much use out of them sadly
yeah again you know you see yo you want
to chat right now yo there's a lot of
break oh shut up - the breakneck love
and I love seeing it everybody's like
it's like murders murdered rip yeah I
love breakneck man it does it does pay
me to see it like this what especially
el rhetorics as well just you know they
got to do something with the turnaround
time it just sucks it seems like the
cadence is still one major sandbox
update first you know turn thing and I
just you just wish they'd be a little
bit more agile on that
I mean provided resources are there that
kind of thing yeah so we got one more
well that is one more changes coming
that's too much sir
yes we got actually two more but um yeah
one-eyed masks Titans over all the world
are rejoicing right now change the maybe
five matches in my life I don't I've
never used it no no let's say I'm like
shooting my son as a foot by not but I
really I've never used it much like
honor respect you know yeah we saw that
so yeah changed you change the effects
of vengeance
remove the over shield granted from
defeating opponent that inflicted damage
on you in a previous sandbox update
one-eyed mass received some tuning and
how vengeance was applied to Titans next
season this perk will continue to
provide health regeneration when
defeating an opponent that has inflicted
damage upon your guardian but it will no
longer grant an over shield additionally
the team is addressing some feedback
concerning the newly released
xenophanes exotic and we talked about
Center phage increased PvE damage by 50%
damage pull from PvP crates has been
increased so four to four to six from
three to four from change and solo heavy
ammo crates respectively zero phase
unintentionally shipped a little weak so
it's getting a bump in raw damage
machine guns have a higher ammunition
capacity than any other heavy weapons
trading or DPS for ease of use
Xena phage slides further down other
heavy weapons towards can be shot
further towards other heavy weapons such
as grenade launchers in that aspect but
but didn't get enough power back this
will correct that and then they said in
the next few weeks we'll have further
sandbox patch notes pay it with some
quality of life changes to things like
escalation protocol armor bug fixes and
more so let's get those two men one-eyed
and zeno where we act I mean everybody's
talked about one I had forever
I mean shotgun aping with a Titan whole
slowdown for sure I mean absolutely will
so it's like if you're giving it a
shotgun
Hill you're not gonna get a kill get an
over shield pick up specially I'm gonna
go run and do it again now you still
have the tracking you still get healing
no you're not exactly and they're still
stronger when after they kill you too
um that is a question I just seen I
don't think I've mentioned seem to
mention was to health regeneration but I
don't know about the stronger part cuz
that's the way the buff typically works
they just did they remove the over
shield but if you're stronger after you
get a kill of by somebody who killed you
still powerful you can see through again
these both these both feel minor versus
some that are major outliers so in my
mind we'll have to see and I just don't
know if they're enough of these to
really move to shift them out of the
meta I mean if you're still gonna get
healing see through walls and if you
kill somebody you're gonna be more
powerful that's still pretty freakin
amazing like a shield so I have a
comment on that when you finish go up
for me it doesn't seem like it's still
gonna like hit it that hard to me I hate
you sent to me I actually I'm on the
other side I think the the problem I had
was the over shield because it was like
they're so tanky at that point it's like
when you you you confront your one-eyed
mass killer when you see him and he's
got that green bar it is demoralize you
know you are not winning that engagement
and god damn trucks today yeah it's
crazy
yeah that was fun I love it but anyway
um yeah so my whole thing is I think
that definitely helps them from being
super over aggressive um yes they still
can track you which is powerful I'll
give you that they still know where you
are that is a huge huge deal I guess for
me health regeneration kind of plays
like devourer to be so that at least if
you shoot them it'll stop the region
you know I'm saying but if you shoot
someone with that over shield it's tanky
it's you're not really gonna be able to
get through so yeah I mean that's that's
what I'm at with it I'll be it I felt it
was I felt it was a decent nerve I don't
I gotta see how a place I again the
other things you're saying makes sense
but um yeah I just I think I actually
like it I want to see how a place I
think I'm on the other side
I think this still is gonna be strong
but not crazy you know I'm saying it's
cuz you showered to Daniel s he's like
the amount of times I'm shooting the
blank out of a tighten charging at me
MVP the moonship well he's about
shoulder charge a that's another don't
get me started don't will will yeah we
already split we're at the realm that
everyone knows how the last word feel
the digital cheetah feel about said so
to charge but um straining moving on
discuss that but uh yeah it's Z no fade
yeah I mean let's call him what it is
xenophanes was hot garbage like let's
just this thing I might feel right late
okay this is where I have an issue
sonic the bug gun xenophanes all the bug
stuff in there liven up have the right
glow replica Guardian Conan comes out
like it's shooting peanuts like I don't
know how you let it go and come out that
week like yeah this is fine the whole
worlds like this feels like trash are
you sure trash yeah it's totally fine
ship it
are you shy group product manager um
project manager director of product okay
everybody's signing off it's like
somebody missed key a number and it's
like is supposed to do twenty thousand
damage and it's doing ten it's like I
don't it's weird and somebody it's the
machine gun and a machine gun having
like 30 bullets I'm sorry but I don't
really care how hard it hits it doesn't
feel right bro I've never listened and
thing needs to have 50 bullets and have
the 50% like again 50% Amy's defense 50%
damages
strong you know we gotta say I play but
I get I'm like you II like do we really
see ourselves putting this in our exotic
slot and heavy do we are we really gonna
stop taking what's the top tiers well
because we must take out our legendary
lyrium de Larry with hammerhead
dammit like this anyways all three of
those cover your types of damage and
they have a ton more shots cuz I mean
the big thing about machine guns the
benefit of them for me especially doing
some of the dumb stuff that I do is the
ability to kill rank-and-file like red
miners with like a bullet here and a
bullet there we'll finally 30 bullets I
feel like I can't be as free cuz I don't
need to one shot him with a rocket a
mini rocket launcher I still need to one
shot him with just a heavy bullet not
Rob you know a Urania depleted-uranium
around that's gonna friggin explode like
so me and no damage
what Jeff Phineas said it I started
little girls about to say next it's like
the no crate damage to me is more
egregious that's the bugs do you like
that should that be bye-bye and that's
more I want I would rather they not even
a sheet that takes away from the
accuracy otherwise I may as well just
shoot him in the chest oh the foot
exactly just like why why would you even
do it so again is my thing is this if
they're gonna around them leave put in
the creek damage and leave the ammo low
so at least we know for those few shots
it's gonna hit crazy hit a mass of 30
bullets they better hit like Mac trucks
every time every time yeah I'm saying
and then what else we got what's the
competition we got what we got breath
now of Leviathan we evolved breath in
there we got um what's are still heavies
of choice teased a we still got whisper
you know I'm saying we still you've got
well isn't Nagas is probably stronger
than this thing inside ammo kinetic but
in fairness infantis said the heavy slot
what's the competition objectively so
it's not the fastest thing so you still
can pump out a bazillion bullets with
like delirium especially if you get 200
in a clip you're just literally sending
a spray of bullets for 200 you don't
have to stop for a while doesn't it is
hard but I will be very clear
if you go like a hundred bullets of em
hmm I need to do like math damage and go
shoot Gregg with this thing whenever
because even with 50% more damage still
don't think it's gonna matter it doesn't
feel like it's enough I'ma be real chewy
this is probably the worst debuting
exotic I've seen from them it's it's
hard pressed to find too many eggs eyes
I want to say this thing was super hyped
but it had like you said lose that
garlic on we saw the they know they've
been hyping you don't you're not yeah
you're right you write your help you
guys on the calendar it's not worth it
at it's part of the dungeon quest now
granted as I said before the wish in
turbo also doesn't blow me away and now
one came from the dungeon so what is up
with these dungeon exotics get in the
shaft
yes what's going on man shout out all
Hodel shout out to love with speed of
light pain
he said sleeper sim actually needs a mom
man you've been think I've been on the
same type of time man like at least a
PvE damage or whatever but anyway you
know yeah you're right
tons of hype for this thing it's now
gonna fall into it wish in the category
it was a son quest like the quests are
more fun than the gun is to use that
doesn't why why is that a thing these
look like some of the coolest things you
go through and get and then you get them
you're like that's fun yeah bro you want
incentive to go back in there right you
want those crazy like this should have
been 1,000 voices level like right like
this should have been that like like
that to me is what you throw on a
dungeon like you don't throw this low
again I'm gonna be nice let's see what
the 50% do this coming from the guy who
didn't even get it the real way I mean I
had no scream he's like rock gets you a
quick four he's like dude I can get it
for you right on alright alright so
let's do a say it was like a labor of
love
it's it's probably worth it easily for
your efforts took you 54 my friend
tripped in through the geometry book me
and my brother a little longer so I know
the real way is just yeah it's just it's
not it's like it's a cool method the
dungeons awesome and then we get a gun
that like I don't know 50% damage bonus
plus carrots if I've only got 30 bullets
they all need to hit like a mini sniper
they do we go bro shop to vagabond
Ordovician above was required to get all
his eggs and truck yeah right they got a
buff these things man buff buff those
other exotics man I really need that
that you know that that levels it to be
able to compete we need that man we want
other options you know it's especially a
harder content we got we gotta get more
than so that is me so yeah we've got one
night mask and recluse big outliers
hopefully being brought back down ish
we'll see how those land
xenophanes getting bumped up ish we'll
see where that yeah all in all though
like these are some pretty minor tweaks
so some major outliers and then yes we
know we're gonna have some sandbox
changes we'll get some tweaks we know I
bet Soler's probably gonna get looked at
cuz solar is gonna be part of the season
of dawn so there's gonna be some look at
there
yes overall kind of a weird weird time
and destiny yeah we're in this little
limbo phase before before the final
assault we don't know what's coming next
we're not entirely sure where the
low-level caps gonna move or not what
the fact the reset the mods are going
away so it's this weird like three weeks
before how much more effort do I put in
until mmm nice little slate cleaning on
most of it not all of it but a lot of it
gets wiped away right now as it
currently sits still forsaken number one
for me I'm just as of currently because
the books not finished still taking King
number two right now it's in the battle
shout out to my voice to speed of light
but it's in a battle of rise of iron
right now anyhow it ends is gonna say a
lot cuz I think it's it's right there
there's a lot of things that um shadow
cube does a little better with the
activities but then there's a lot of
things with longevity that I
still feel um you know being done there
the raids are fairly really even I think
um I think I think a lot of people
really love rat I'm never gonna
disrespect right I love Ryan to wrap
this is really cool um you know we got a
lot like garden to be honest I do like
all the salvation you know so that
that's a good debate but in shadow keeps
defense shadow keep has that pit pit of
heresy and I'm saying that's that's a
big deal we got to see it's coming down
to the wire for third place that's who's
the third and this is nothing it's not
like a bad thing it's just that
no listen Forsaken and taken King bro
come on that doles change the game so
right now
dizzy stop it shadow keep my kids very
dizzy so disrespectful right now its
battling for the third my third favorite
DLC from where were you at where where's
your rank from be in the same boat I
mean I like what the artifact has
potential for because mods the reloads
the champions are kind of cool they're
their own thing you've got these like
impressive darkness and unfortunately
broken hunters in PvP and stuff like
that's like thieves it's all over the
place but I like the idea of some stuff
that is just like cool like a pimp if
they break it okay if it's not maybe
they put it in later
I love the dungeons man we get a dungeon
and a raid and the moon and array yeah
and then you know you go rise of iron
and you go half the plate you go to play
glands which mmm what's cool but not as
big as the moon and Wrath is cool garden
also cool first time through those
fights
I like God man I do like it
so I think but then you have other
glaring things staring at you
yes vendors just they're like sticks
sitting there with their thumb up their
butt like I'm just over here chillin
giving you the same guns like devran k
is not do anything now they mentioned in
that in the 12 about like escalation
protocol armor and stuff like that and I
was like oh yeah okay
as this Laker are those gonna start to
get stat roles
like quality of life changes things like
escalation protocol armor like you don't
have to go to rank 7 or you can work on
it and just like a random roles you
don't have to wait on the five-week
rotation maybe that's what they're
talking about and then this is where
they take like a step forward and step
back at the same time stab on the armor
for me is like it's cool but also many
people have pointed out the only good
places for stats seem to be iron banner
mm-hmm I don't even know if the raids
are guarantee like raid armors not even
drop it like the pinnacle drops
specifically to oh the between Bane's
the worst the dungeon armor when you get
it at the end the dream bane armor
I got ace Master worked so that's with
the must well with the plasto 60 it was
a phony role so like the dream Bane is
like force to be low that's one thing
I've been listening to braid look I'm
saying outrageous round time he seems to
think like the affection Ellis there's
another one that's a whole different
trialing ball of wax mm-hmm
yeah I heard you what do you say yeah
what do you say what do you say what do
you say about a shadow just like the
dream paint armor it's like will not
roll high like it doesn't seem to be and
that's one thing with me that it's
bugging the living hell out of me is
like coffee if you want to go for a good
stat rule there's not a lot of places to
say hey I want to go for some blade I
want to go somewhere where I can roll
get the whether it's at 950 nightfall
whether it's a master and I feel like I
don't have incentive to go do some stuff
right now and bash my head against
something ridiculous because say I do
get some gloves what if it's like a 51
stat roll and it's kind of trashed like
there's no there's no more to say this
is where you level this is where you
take it to the next tier of your tier 10
I want to go to tier 11 I want to go
little step above I don't need to break
in but I need to work on you know stat
mods and that's just like that's one of
those things where it's like it's
bugging me yeah I'm wit bro I'm which
think shout out to dramatic he said he
got 271 no no this is good Vince bro did
this is what we've been talking about
right we we need pinnacle if you're
limiting pinnacle sources then
damn well done pinnacle so drops better
be powerful so they better they better
be people won't need to be envious of
the drops that you get from these d
sources so yeah you know I'm saying like
that that is a big deal I didn't even
realize that the dungeon or Melissa was
that and I'm saying like that's yeah
that's that that's a bit low a little
much so yeah they got they gotta clean
that up that's why I said they need for
me they need to end strong they need to
n strong so they can maintain otherwise
you know we may have to reevaluate their
ranking but again not a terrible deal
see buddy me he's not saying I just
don't know really literally a lot like
to turn I've enjoyed a lot of what's
been there the opening the cinematics
the missions the memories the moon the
vex invasion gives the moon that's nice
like in flux and change the next minute
was cool we got the pit we got the
garden leg huh I love the narrative arty
we love Wars we got 34 hours crap load
of stuff I love the narrative beat we
love the narrative beat from the start
of season space debris dolls we loved
all that you know I'm saying and strong
maybe cool I'm not gonna be greedy be
like oh they need some type of secret
being like a what you call it cuz
they've given us a lot I'm not gonna say
they need a zero hour or something like
that nothing like that but um you know
and strong narrative Lee whatever you
start please make it make it cool and
yeah hopefully they'll add a little more
drops you know throughout
you don't say actually I'll spread out
another couple of pinnacle drops
throughout maybe hopefully with dis vex
offensive activity as well that's what
I'm hoping for
yeah some more pinnacles and but yeah
the big thing for me is stats and
affinities I'm still kind of here there
I guess I wouldn't matter as much on
affinities if I knew there was at least
some chats the stats would be decent
outside of iron banner iron banners
literally all my best - yeah that is the
only ones that are like typically 57 58
59 mace do in those I might actually
like take but I'm not gonna go you know
spend these ridiculous hundred thousand
ridiculous currency on something looks
like oh it's a 50 to start role not even
gonna love won't even consider it it's
no point I agree
and the worst part is I went through my
item manager because I hadn't deleted
all my old armor some of my old armor
now has defaulted to 60s Wow yeah I have
60s on old armor and I'm like okay I'll
use like some of those have some decent
roles like 911 targeting and lavender or
reserves with like a 60s that rule
that's better than anything I see that
they want us to shift those should not
be that way for one that's weird for the
old to the new one should have an option
so and for the love of God bring the
enhanced mod costs down some of these
targeting codes and some of these are
not like six like come on like yeah
basically you lock that person in you
know if you're a guy that's not using
your ascendant whatever those things are
prisms or whatever they're like if
you're in that I would say I'm in that
if I like someone that's seven range
eight is when I push it I have eight is
about my love is bent anything at eight
yet wow I've been I've only taken it to
seven because I have enhancement cores
but the prisms what do I have eleven or
twelve I don't love anything enough to
go no exotic style those are even more
expensive those cost more problems I
have honestly not that many great
exotics but nothing's like helped a
build they've all been kind of outliers
of just Mugur they're technically yes
and exotic with an okay role but I don't
usually find a lot of use for the ones
I've got so far my exotic centigrade I
may have had a few but they've not been
helpful you're interested in me yeah I
mean I've probably used on two separate
armors but I think one was Nazareth in
the other one I got this really cool
riff filled with arc Souls with armed
Vesper of radiance and it's one of my
favorite builds right now I'm having so
much fun with it and I also throw
Thunder coil or one of my other joints
but um yeah like I'm that's about I'll
go get me wrong I'm very selective I've
only used it to tie guess I said those
two times but um again oh yeah
no I ain't doing that
I just - my life it's salaah problems or
you got to do the 980 nightfall and 950
nightfall hallo final what I'm jumping
it when I'm jumping in the backpack
let's go don't go for this yeah there we
go
that would take a lot of practice but
it's the pyramidion I've done it before
I can oh yes a solo player link
izanagi's is next - required
oh absolutely this week because like you
have to kill the barrier I don't have
the catalyst so I've got to get that I
did it without the catalyst so you you
and I'm actually shot the gaming addict
at me too - he just got stood on me so
you got two people get your chalice done
man get you easy paralysis done it's
been done I just never in the heroic
let's go hit me I love that I mean the
line is like trying to find I am and you
just got a planet with me just tell me
ahead of time when you want to do it
that's I'll be here let's do it
love menagerie shop the for actually did
Bellagio yeah two nights ago it was
regular but shout to a game before take
a nautical we had a couple of stuff on
there but um I love that activity still
mad I still it's fun Jamie varieties
nice because you may not even have the
same runs that's why it's there's so
direction for the quick short little
encounters you get a little variety it's
not always the same fun like that's a
fun activity that gives for a season not
always seeing the same run helps with
the variety as opposed to here's the
same path up the same set of stairs
through the grass you know every time
like mmhmm yeah the variety I mean
menagerie was Minesh I'm saying the way
yeah yeah no menagerie is still good
good but yeah whatever the thing about
it though is that I like is also I was
running a shot the Forte who never got a
chance to see the gauntlet in count he'd
never saw yeah they got the gauntlet so
he was he was all excited but I'm the
thing that's dope though is that I was I
was like you know what
let me fill up my chalice and I'm
looking at all my armor pieces on my
wait a minute I've got some cool mods
and void for chests I don't have a void
chest right now
so I literally Specht out my chalice to
pick out I love it with the new armor
2.0 yeah you can get really creative
with your armor drops and stuff like
that so yo it's still viable to do man
if you live again if you have mods in a
specific affinity and stuff like that
y'all run Menagerie get that bad boy
then also you get it you get some um
some specific Leviathan mods which I use
running Leviathan that so now I will say
this I which I do like about ARMA 2.0 I
have a Leviathan set bro okay I have
some opulent armor I got a whole bunch
of perks that I could again pray stone
affinity that's like killing me 50%
energy damage give me stuff heavy drops
and it's really really fun man so I will
remember we always wanted you know
certain armors to be effective and to
have that kind of functionality in race
this is the closest we've I feel we've
come but you just got to run those
activities to get it so yeah definitely
on some stuff for sure mm-hmm but other
Nets was pretty light they've got some
stuff out there basically this a time
never stops festival velocity yelling
for more days so if you're going for
triumphs
get your butt in there momentum control
is going away
I do hope they keep that in the rotation
like I would like to see that come
through the 66 just every so often
because it is it makes the game feel
different I know it's a ton of scout
rifles and things go quick but the
occasional times you need to grind quest
and so it has some cool benefits and
it's just fun to be completely anti meta
yes legs it's a nice change a wrench
into everything and it's a good way to
mix it up so I just hope that one comes
through in its rotation get show
catalyst brothers get UK I gotta get
Mazda and get that catalyst done man
those are the best way with momentum
control get them scouts
seriously anything mm-hmm yeah but for
me that is mostly all I've been doing in
the world
yes sir you pretty well caught up his
all yeah I'm pretty much caught up man
um like I said is on the tune in next
week to see what seven probably still
gonna be farming some specific things
from raids I guess my new type of time
now I'm I'm more in like this arm
getting mods and certain weapons and
title stuff for from old raids so I'm
I'm in this Leviathan kick right now I
want to get spire done I'm c4 sleeper I
want to get Telesto catalyst I'm gonna
get out the way I didn't get my accuracy
on PC so I'm just want to clean it I've
been in this raid mode of like old Rob
actually if he's do I gotta check in on
piracy if he's doing all right but um I
want to hit power up and I want to give
him
yeah I know I know when things settle
down hopefully for him and again you
know salute my condolences to his family
you know I'm saying but um yeah by just
trying to organize ratings and um yeah
get some most stuff done their work or I
know this guy's still going for Anarchy
things like that I don't mean either
yeah that's been my my end game so to
speak yeah like running the old race
like yeah like just having fun with that
before I get ready to that and then this
weekend just touching you know a lot of
you know these games come on we got Jedi
fallen order you already know you know
I'm saying out of worlds I still been
rocking and yeah that's that's been
pretty much it I just want to say also
next week looks like the stadia launch
is happening right they believe that's
coming they just gotta give a shout out
shout out to exile for killing them on
arrival they'll saluted its Lucas book
because there's enough videos out there
that abashed everything that is we
launched not going well how's it yeah
the street pre-orders are like gonna be
spaced out you're not gonna have all the
features they promised things are like
in a trial the chromecast has got to get
updated but it's not live at first
controller only is gonna work at the
chromecast not on pc but wireless i'm
like what like that's a lot of stuff for
a system like and then this is again of
course like google behind it and it's it
could be but I can definitely tell you
they're not putting the strong foot
forward to start yeah shut up
I got we got shot their Lords game with
that net we got a great article on
stadia
check it out of my way undead it almost
feels like a glorified beta they feels
like a beta right now you know I mean
and then you pay for the service mm-hmm
and then you still pay for the games yes
individually like there's like it's uh I
thought a long time ago I actually
thought about was like hey maybe I can
literally take the chromecast ultra puck
in a controller when you have to like
you know visit family or something
played up there might be cool I didn't
do it they about to be DOA let me tell
you why real quick shot the EXO 19 that
went down
Prabhas cloud not only did they announce
that they are also going to be used
utilizing it in their browser which a
lot of people had an issue as dr.
people's like hey I don't want to play
on this I don't want to use my phone to
play games they're gonna put it on a
browser that's number one number two
they just announced like 50 games and EA
as part of it and you know Destiny's
coming so all you I'd literally they've
included into game pass so all you gotta
have is game pass and have this plethora
of library of games with the
functionality for it it sounds like for
free but in a sense for free right you
get all this stuff where a state is like
oh I got you can't you only use specific
phone and oh I got a by destiny
individually again and then yeah it's
looking spooky I hate that I I'm not I'm
using a person that's very you know I'll
say optimistic but you know try to be
positive it don't look good right now
you know especially what this stuff that
ice cloud is announcing so yeah that's
that that's that's that but I am curious
to see how the launch goals I won't tell
launch I'm curious to see how destiny
plays on Stadium that's what I want to
see like this play with stadia people
because there that there is no cross
play for their sake they're only playing
with destiny people so if you think I
mean you don't have last mission oh yeah
I'm real curious about that matchmaking
over 12 people in the stand like every
lobby be like oh this guy's good
[Music]
12 yo you fool well yeah it's crazy
yeah we'll see we'll see man that's what
I get yeah so I mean if you were Pokemon
fans sword and shield case yes today or
yesterday night mimic whatever um it's
out
I haven't played Pokemon since red blue
and yellow mmm I literally jumped into
fall outs twitch cuz he was streaming it
and I was like dude I've played it so I
have not played a full pokemon in so uh
so like I know I'll be doing some
driving and stuff like that so I might
pick it up for it I'm not picking it up
right now but like okay I haven't played
one of those in so long I'm actually
like curious the lake maybe slept out on
the switch and take it on the go yeah
gotta pull it out and see what's up man
yeah there's a lot of good games man a
lot of good games there's like and then
of course for you guys if you're
watching this one live or you just
follow me on Twitch Star Wars whoa
so this is the one I'm excited about so
I didn't want to talk about it a little
bit what have you learned before I get
into what I've heard roughly from yeah
we're using notions what it might be
like yeah listen man I mean as far as
you know shout to respawn I'm a huge
respawn fanboy I my pin I don't feel
they've ever made a bad game um
obviously punches one of my favorite
developers but respawn is is in my top
top three and I'm saying to be honest
you like I love me some reason more so I
got a chance what is it III 2018 last
year um to see that then yeah see this
thing behind closed doors and I'm
telling you right now I am NOT a Star
Wars game fan I'm not a hardcore Star
Wars game guy I'm just not I mean I'm a
casual guy that like you know why
watches the franchise but I wouldn't
consider myself hardcore I get every
game when I left that behind the seeing
viewing of this game my mouth did the
floor the things I saw with the
manipulation of the lightsaber using it
as a weapon coming back manipulating
enemies for sport it was so cool then it
had like platforming then you got the
cinematic aspects of like an uncharted
it was like yo then they had wall
running
which is my thing from titanfall when
you kind of skedaddle on a walk I said
man they got it I said this they got one
I am in on this and I on the cake is the
combat the combat and the Dark Souls
aspect you know which I'm probably gonna
struggle with but you know I do want to
support this game you know I love
respawns thing that make us at a
titanfall series and the makers of the
original Call of Duty's that I grew up
with the modern warfare is those classic
ones that's Vincent Pella that those are
my guys and I got to support it man it's
good to see just thing out from I saw
the medic red came out looking strong
so yeah the only bomb only mad that it's
not free trial on EA access like most EA
access game they must do this game was
good day like a given that but it shout
to my boy he he said its own premiere
right there for a piece of you like I
bought it for anthem yes some hours of
play this is definitely gonna be also
included in there so cost me a diamond
it's gonna be freaking amazing so I'm a
to Dark Souls lightsaber battles and
deliberate combat cinematic story 2013
crazy fun Star Wars and I heard kind of
funny basically mentioned it's it's a
gamers game there's a little bit of like
old-school like pulls II said there's
uncharted there's platform there's a
little Metroidvania where you got to go
oh yes unlock stuff with abilities later
and then you have the combat and the
dodging and the pairing and I'm like
yeah all of the above
yep you're in bro and I'm tell you right
now that game makes you feel powerful
once you start mastering skills like you
feel like a job you feel like it is it
is really cool so I'm in I'm with you
and I'm actually opening up my origin
what you told me that I bid yes or that
does desperate yeah I know you hype I
know yeah I'm pretty pumped just cuz I
mean Sakura was a blast Dark Souls 3
blood-borne still probably my top is
blood
all of those Secor was cool Sager it was
like a switch cuz you're like getting
the hell out of the way and the second
row you're like stand in the way but
time it right and I'm like this is
backwards for me oh dude like so much
hard as hell still believe me button
also a ton of fun and this is if this
can scratch that itch even like halfway
oh man plus the Star Wars yeah I'm I'm
just dying over so if you guys want to
watch stay tuned to the channel yes
what's up TV slash Yvonne tests if you
guys won't listen to an audio I will be
playing streaming uploading content
might like trim up some of the
recordings but I will be definitely
playing this one I have no idea if
YouTube is gonna give me like flags on
these things but I'm gonna try and
upload some stuff we'll see made for
kids married [ __ ] that's a new one
that's a whole different discussion
anyway but yeah that'll be that'll be me
split in time between that work and then
finishing Festival this weekend because
that's yes and then at some point I
gotta go through my solo complet that'll
be a discussion for a week and that
actually happens but my brother did it
so I soloed to snow that's was so yeah
that was awesome he just tweeted me he's
like 1200 then he was like Randy's I was
like dude yeah my guys not meeting out
like for days I was like your machine
dude he wants us this is his first title
is gonna be wow he's like me I gotta get
my first for it soon so that's really
good it's kind of a light week last week
we was not allowed to talk about you
were down here so we're like we thought
about doing an in person last word that
really wasn't that much to cover so yeah
we got a couple light weeks as festivals
going on makes you guys spend your
bright dusts hold on ever verse
controversy and things like that on the
cost was kind of see how things net out
but that might be a topic for another
week but I'm gonna let this man get out
to his birthday festivities so let us be
going on this weekend you may be so
drunk there may not even be a last or
yeah there will be no guests this but I
love podcast
professional Sunday for y'all yes it
would just be the Lord's your lead over
know Bo first of all thank everyone for
the birthday which is really appreciate
it really good feels good to feel the
love from everybody man thank you guys
so much
obviously at Lord kognito you already
know it is on Twitter and YouTube on
Sundays 11:00 a.m. Eastern no guest this
week just the Lord's you don't seem but
we can be having some fun we're gonna be
talking about EXO recaps for them to
talk about pokemons we're gonna talk
about said Star Wars you know I mean so
we're really gonna be touching all the
bases on that and yeah also by the way
around for those who aren't subscribed
or not subscribe to the iron law podcast
YouTube channel please when you get a
chance man check us out we got some new
subscriber perks that um really cool
that like kind of if you've been
following the Lord's you know you know
we king of the catchphrases and throw
them in the bushes and you know saying
fill dominate all these crazy sayings
that we usually get people to say so if
you get a chance and if you want to join
the realm please do we got some cool
badges some cool emojis you can earn
your your way from from a peasant to it
to his Knights choir and it's all the
way to a lord so we got these cool yo
dude shop the graphic God he did a
phenomenal job graphic guys also a guy
who did last word y'all so um yo graphic
God's amazing he did the emojis are
hilarious again if you go to our Lord
podcast Twitter you see when we give you
a little sample throw we got we got some
funny woods bad so please again if your
fan Lords it's very inexpensive if you
want to support us we'll also have some
perks behind there behind the scenes
stuff when we at the events two shows
and all that good stuff soul soul or
podcast brothers King David Lord
Sovereign Lord addict you know we just
trying to do something fun for the
community and for you guys so our
support us if you choose if not just
show up in a chat and laugh at the
emotion that's what I got you know yeah
birthday turn-up will be happening oh
yeah I will see the resemblance of some
type of man that you are on Sunday you
guys have fun for me I will be streaming
Star Wars or destiny as much as I can
this weekend between whole bunch other
crap I have going on
I'm gonna get it done but I want to play
so stay tuned to twitch Twitter you guys
know I've got my patreon if you guys do
want to support me directly as well then
for you guys if you guys want to support
the podcast up there in the links in the
description you guys can actually
support the podcast directly so pick any
and all of us spread the love to a
little bits everything but right here on
twitch thank you guys for tuning in if
you're listening to the audio version
thank you guys for listening come find
us on Twitter and YouTube and stuff like
that check out our faces we're funny to
look at at least so that's about all we
got but this has been episode number 81
creeping up towards the hundo yeah 81 it
is he bonta's the cheetah kognito the
ninja whoa thank you guys very much and
for this episode it has been the last
word